sorry guys I'm so busy yeah hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the night of the consumers if
you've ever worked a retail job and I
have in my past I work the customer
service at micro Center Mall in
Cincinnati Ohio you might know that this
game is going to be the most horrible
game that ever existed you know that
people especially shoppers around the
time of Black Friday are the most
devastating shoppers of them all all
right so I'm not exactly sure how scary
this game is gonna be but as it relates
to my life and my experience working
retail I'm imagining it's gonna tap into
a primal sort of fear from my day I hate
it already
what is sorry it's coming in for work
boss just that should not have got me at
all period full stop that should not
have had me in any way shape or form
you're late
alright okay since you're new around
here I'll cut you some slack thanks man
how about you cut that smile some slack
it's getting a little creepy my name is
the manager great name and we're not too
busy on days like these so you can have
a nice easy shift to help you get
settled in but remember I've got a
reputation to uphold
as the creepiest bastard within a 50
mile radius so just you remember you
won't have me looking like a fool in
front of the other managers with you
this store is the best in town and I
would like to keep it that way I will be
hearing about it now go find Jimmy he's
been working here for a while very loyal
employee of mine he will show you the
ropes put your stuff in the locker and
get to it
[Music]
Thanks do I call you though or mr.
manager
oh okay who is it Baldy wait what is
that Baldy from baldies basics it
vaguely looks like Baldy I'm not a
hundred percent sure god damn it Oh oh
my god okay oh this is great hey are you
Steve erse defin or Willard oh my god I
can't take this anymore I don't get paid
enough for this
oh the rude customers the endless
amounts of sick the [ __ ] stays fresh my
breaking point
listen it's up to you now there's still
a lot of empty shelves out there they
need to be stacked before we close you
don't want to upset manager here take
this it's all the notes I've made while
working here those tips saved me time
and time again press escape to view the
note at anytime
whatever that means good luck to hell
with this place excellent hygiene though
great okay Employee of the Month Lester
for outstanding commitment and
attendance
good job Lester Lester missing Oh
well that don't seem too good butter
will hello have a funny feeling this
kind of go oh boy okay oh where the PPE
Lester is the manager's pet he'll
survival notes sweet s
don't get caught hide in the staff only
rooms throw box it stuns them beware the
baby when you're stacking a shelf for
use a and D to look around
[Music]
hello hello hello
video game okay what I do is find the
video game section Oh
video games perfect oh I just oh no I
had that ain't right oh here oh god no
no not like this Oh No blah is that the
baby
oh okay
what do we do do I just go for it what
happens if they get me oh my god oh my
god oh oh my god okay well that's not so
bad
poised simple enough where was toys ah
poison this old lady I'm just can I
avoid that all the other okay boys Oh
flesh birds this is the people that done
made flesh birds okay oh god these are
awful look hi that might have been a bit
of an overreaction sorry guys I'm so
busy
[Music]
oh god oh god Furniture Furniture
Furniture a health and beauty I'm dead
I'm dead I'm done I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead
oh my god okay this game is horrible
this might be one of the worst games
I've ever played in terms of spookiness
holy crap that was terrifying
okay good purchase okay yeah okay never
mind they've got me sweets where the
hell are they I don't know man I don't
know I would think of being here sweets
here we go
there you go you're welcome my dude
you're welcome my dude so so if I've got
the place memorized and I should have no
problem right if you're quick it's more
of them in one go I think okay perfect
[Music]
okay just gotta start this Yahoo is okay
that's three that's good that's very
good
[Music]
little DIY DIY why do we have a DIY
section oh my god I was about to take my
third shot of the day but I'm out of
shampoo got a state clean for the ladies
you right oh my god Shampoo where would
shampoo be I don't know I don't know
home cleaning health and beauty health
and beauty there you go there you go
[Music]
okay oh my god this is no joke this is
legitimately no joke it's [ __ ] scary
bro okay we're with DIY be weirwood DIY
B I don't know oh my god oh my god oh my
god okay it would be some kind of a oh
now I see the furniture aisle it would
be some kind of a in one of these aisles
I oh my god oh my god I lost my baby
five baby there you go there there you
go I think DIY okay let's just get this
on here yeah paint paint yep DIY this
that's DIY alright okay good hey I'm
doing good yeah I've got this game maybe
working retail ain't that bad huh
everything's looking up for me I don't
need to worry about a thing
everything's for you no thank you no
thank you don't take you know I'm busy I
got a stock the pan
then I dog toys oh you're in luck
I actually am ugh right here you're
welcome
dog soup is that super major you where
do you keep the fake blood oh I would be
all the ween sorry sorry sorry sir oh
god oh god oh god fake blood fake blood
Halloween Halloween Halloween what do I
have pharmacy Oh God just give me a
break this game might be one of the most
stressful games I've ever played in my
life I think I need to get one more I
think that's why it says five I don't
know where pharmacy is more than a drink
my friend oh god okay okay that's there
and then I need to quench my dry crusty
throat yeah yeah I got you got you buddy
all right I just need to get to pharmacy
I need to get this I just got to get
miracle cream yep everyone needs a cream
everyone needs to cream everyone needs
cream
[Applause]
[Music]
am I done can I go home what is this
kitchen okay kitchen it's down there
just trying to make sure it's all clear
it's not but that's okay here we go
great knives yep that's what we want oh
no Halloween direction yeah wasted by oh
god yeah yeah you ready you ready you
ready waste money okay just a couple
more so when the music kicks up they
phase on the way is what I've just
learned when the music go up they are
coming for my nuts what do you keep the
skincare price I'm 82 if you wouldn't
believe oh I believe it all right oh god
please don't let me lose it now health
and beauty here we go okay you know what
I think I just want to go I think I want
to go home I think I have enough theirs
I've definitely the clock is about to
I'm just gonna hide out in here collect
my money from the manager and I'm gonna
get the hell out of here this game is no
joke this game is terrifying and it
brings me back to my days of working
retail god I work oh [ __ ]
fired
what do you mean fired what did I do
wrong what did I do wrong
drinks Oh what did I do wrong face hi hi
roasted peanuts got any yeah right over
here food oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god I don't know
what I did wrong was it because I ended
the game when I was out and not in the
area is that why yo where the screws at
dude I don't even know where would the
screws be none on their DIY here we go
no no no oh my god
cool kids juice gotta get it okay I'm
doing great I'm doing so good
I'm doing the best I've ever done that's
North Halloweeny okay Halloween
Halloween Halloween Halloween oh my
[ __ ] criminy
you know Petey clone games yeah yeah got
him right there no oh good that's not
spooky at all I guess it's actually a
marginally less spooky than people's
actual faces in this game is man those
phases are spotty pet food okay
[Music]
frickin Frick drinks yeah uh-huh
man I hate I hate that I'm learning the
layout of this store because it reminds
me of when I was working both Micro
Center and Kroger I don't like it I got
real good at knowing where everything
was but no that doesn't make me happy
what's the toys on this side or was toys
on the toys on the set okay orrible okay
good I'm I think I did it I think the
problem was that I was in the staff area
when the game ended last time this games
no problem because I know exactly where
everything is and I'm such an expert
high your baby god find your freaking
baby oh my god oh my god oh come on come
on come on where is she where is she
where'd she go there's our baby take
your cut damn baby oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my
hey look it's cool kids juice I've heard
this is all the rage cleaning okay mom
cleaning you could move thank you
new toaster was at kitchen there you go
no no no no no no no like a cleaning god
no your baby damn baby
oh my god there's your stupid baby just
let me do this get home cleaning where
is it not here you know what you know
what you know what I get to get another
one pharmacy perfect pharmacy I can deal
with whoa oh yes yes yes yes yes I got a
five didn't get you I need a little bit
of the bubbly there you go you're a
freak
wait wait I'm confused what do I know oh
god what do I need to do exactly what am
i what am I in need of wait cuz the
number after I picked up the box
oh is that just the aisle it's in does
that just mean it's in Aisle five no
full brick chef oh yeah yeah okay um how
the media I'm so confused
am I not what am i what am I doing wrong
what what am I doing wrong boss I'm
stuck and I did I'm sorry I'm a little
confused as to what the objective is
let me try something what if I strat
strategize it like you know there's only
so many boxes right so what if I put the
boxes where they need to go before I
even start my shift and that way I know
exactly where that box for that aisle is
it's right next to the place that way I
can be the most efficient about it and
if I do get caught with my pants down I
just got to come back to where the box
is and Bob's your uncle I'm done maybe
that's the thing maybe I gotta get all
of it okay I think I've got all the
boxes out of the area and next to where
they need to go I think anyway so I'm
gonna start over from here on the pet
section I'm gonna go from here Emma
oh hi you're here soon okay video game
what nope what what video game right
here video game what old magazine
magazine Oh Rick u4q man almost cost me
the game right off the bat after all my
Pratt because I didn't know his magazine
oh god hi yes what you again magazine
yeah see how I was gonna do that
whatever doing good doing great actually
doing just the best better than the rest
okay
doing real good I found where the
cleaning was by the way it's on the
outside here of the middle the middle of
the outside the outside middle whoa what
the hell hey hi hey how you doing hey
cleaning stuff I will you're in luck I
just got that yep
though sorry wrong actual aisle
thank you God you suck uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
purchase purchase purse I walk in you I
wanna help you
good turn it up a little bit oh yeah you
you do that you do that I started over
here no no no no hi hi four nine
magazine how many times have I led you
to the goddamn for die magazine I've
done it many many many times now and I
don't need to keep doing it
oh really great yeah that's great
I need something to read how about a
magazine god why does everyone need a
magazine all of a sudden oh really
we're gonna be doing it like this now
are we yeah just let me get my goddamn
drinks put in get my goddamn cool kids
juice that's why everyone's after me all
right well how many more do I have left
there's just gotta be like one more oh
no no no no no no oh god I
right what do you need but sugar in it
well yep sure do bud sure do bud bud
I've got you all taken care of
hardly food it's ketchup yeah hope I did
it I did it I think I did it I
definitely think I did it I must say I'm
quite impressed yeah someone's so eager
so passionate so yeah you're exactly
what I've been looking for keep this up
and you'll be nominated for employee of
the month
only the most deserving hard-working
employees are granted such an honor
I'm going to invite all the managers
from the other stores over
I need them to see what a fine specimen
you you know you remind me of someone
else who used to work here full of
discipline and determination then oh my
oh my he was a fine employee oh how it
saddened me when he stopped turning up
for work here's exam tomorrow sharp aha
oh well there you have it that is night
of the customer was no one's fault I
don't even remember what it was called
something horrible about customer not at
night of the consumers surprising always
carry legitimately surprisingly scary
but anyway hope you enjoyed it if you
did you can play this game for yourself
through the link in the description
below and I look forward to seeing more
of this game coming out because it is
just the right mixture of reality and
absolute abject or or I hate it but I
love it so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]